Depuis des siècles, un mystérieuxphénomène transforme les côtes
de la Guyane. Le littoral se déplace,des forêts de mangroves apparaissent.
Perdue au milieu d'une naturesauvage et hostile, une équipe
de scientifiques intrépides décide de percer ce mystère.
Sur mer, sur terre et dans lesairs, ces aventuriers d'un nouveau
genre vont tenter de cartographier le
littoral le plus dynamique du monde.
Une quête de réponses, pour comprendre les
transformations d'un territoire oùl'Homme est à la merci de la nature.
Cet été envolez-vous pourune aventure hors du commun,
à la découverte de phénomènes qui
n'ont pas fini d'étonner la science.